in IMAX you'll be able to see 26% more  image on the top and bottom of the frame  so if you could have 26% more of  anything in the world what would it be  goodness I've just gone straight to  trees I think we need all those trees  that we've cut down I don't know it  sounds a really like earnest answer 26%  more of anything you want what would it  be time with family that's a great one  that's a great one I was gonna say Tracy  just have more fun but I probably  couldn't have more fun around  so much fun already I'm Peter by the way  dr. strange Oh  using your made-up names then I am  spider-man 26% more chance of us making  it as a species are not screwing up the  planet map / twenties more percent  poppies  [Music]  [Music]